for a lot of things I'm going to talk
about now uh so the title of the talk is
privacy In fairness and collaborative AI
but more specifically I'll be talking
about uh free learning which is work
I've been doing during my postdoc with
someone investment USC
so uh following up on the talk Box live
view and talking morning the idea is
that we have nowadays a lot of data
generated
um that is very close to who we are so
it's with our interactions with the
environment other our biological
interactions or talking with people
things that we do in our life and so on
and with this huge amount of data is
very useful for machine learning models
but it also brings to the Limelight the
issue of trustworthiness which is a big
part of the this workshop and the
trustworthiness we can look at it the
theme has been throughout the last
couple of days there's one side of
privacy let's say yesterday and also
today there's been a lot of talks on uh
fairness and machine learning models so
um in order to be able to access and
make use of these data we need to have
some sort of guarantees on data privacy
and group fairness as we have alluded to
uh so
one way to access data that users have
that has been recently uh proposed in
the community I mean not recently it's
been
fiction for years but which is fairly
learning and the idea is that instead of
uh centralizing uh instead of
centralizing data access we actually uh
leave the ownership of the data to the
users and we want to train a machine
learning model using some parameter
server so to use our strain uh the model
locally and then we aggregate these uh
local model updates at the server and
keep repeating that and in this way
we're refining the model training
now the uh after this initial
proposition it's come in a lot of
different papers issues with just
sending model updates is that not
sending data and just sending gradients
for example is not necessarily enough to
protect the data privacy for example
um using gradients you can easily
reconstruct images that have been used
in the training so there's need for
doing something more
so
we need to have some privacy guarantees
otherwise users are a little bit
reluctant to share their information
also we can
face some legal
roadblocks to that
but you can also if we bring into the
equation also fairness uh not sharing
features is one thing but you will be
even more protective of sharing the
sensitive attributes that Define you as
an individual
and if we somehow pay in terms of
performance to avoid sharing this
information then uh the penalty that you
get in critical applications such as
Healthcare or credit scoring or higher
ability as well as it is doing previous
talks is a huge consequence
so uh in this talk I'll be looking at
particularly two sides of uh of this
trifecta in particular we're looking
first at privacy from the point of view
not of sick not of the French privacy
but rather using the secure aggregation
algorithm
and we'll be presenting some guarantees
uh for uh what we can actually kind of
protect using secure aggregation and
then we'll be building on that if we're
using secure aggregation to actually uh
present a model for training group
fairness of training a group Fair model
in a Federated learning setting so
without having access to the data how
can we make sure that the modern trained
is fair even when the distributions
across clients are very heterogeneous
okay so the first part of the talk is on
these privacy guarantees and this is uh
worth the soon to appear uh thinking in
July and popets
uh and uh just to uh set the stage we'll
be particularly talk about information
privacy where uh the Privacy violation
is measured by the mutual information
between what uh the data is and what is
actually revealed into the system
so the benefit of approaches that Target
information privacy is that
um you do not get a penalty to the
end-to-end performance but this comes at
cost to the huge cost usually to the
system efficiency
on the current part there is the French
privacy where you randomize the output
in order to make the output distribution
close multi multiplicatively for
enabling inputs and this is a worst case
protection it's definitely more robust
to auxiliary information but it comes at
a cost to the end-to-end performance
so this will be the focus today and uh
typically the most famous approach to
give such guarantees is the use of
secure aggregation which is secure
multi-part computation protocol
so the idea is they start with the large
latest Global model uh you compute the
local updates and then uh these local
updates are typically computed using for
example if you study SGD then you sample
a batch of data points compute the
gradient on it and this is how you
compute the update
and then we would like to send these to
the server so that so that the server
can compute the average of these updates
what you typically do is instead of
sending the XIs uh in the wild you would
uh encrypt them uh using secure
aggregation and one way to do that is
the clients would exchange a pairwise
seed and then use the seat to generate
noise that is common across every pair
one client would add the noise the other
would subtract the noise and this is
done in the finite field domain so the
idea is uh looking at any of the N minus
users the uh whatever is being sent
looks completely uniform but once you
complete the missing piece then you can
actually you are able to compute the the
sum that you'd like
so the guarantee that you get in this
case is can be expressed in terms of
mutual information it's following is
that conditional knowing the sum or the
average the mutual information between
whatever the users have and whatever is
being sent in the system is equal to
zero so there's no leakage in the sense
but the server still gets access to the
average model or the aggregate model and
the question is
how much does the aggregate model leak
about the client state
so uh this is what you'd particularly be
talking about in this part of the talk
uh and we ask this question in an
expanded way in three different facets
one is how do you quantify the leakage
and how does the leakage how's the
leakage affected by the system
parameters and is this actually a good
representative metric
so for the first two we give some
critical entities and we verify these
experimentally and for the last one uh
we demonstrated uh experimentally by
comparing our measurements with our
model inverts and attacks
okay so let me get to the
results uh so the main Central result
that we have is the following it it is a
bond on the amount of on the mutual
information between any individual
update and the aggregate model that the
server computes and this is done for the
FED fgd protocol
so uh this upper bond is is actually a
function of multiple system parameters
in particular uh the ones of huge
interest are the number of clients that
we have in the system which is
characterized here by n the model size
and the local batch size
so as you can see as the size of the
model increases you actually leak more
information because the model can
actually remember more information about
your data
as the number of clients increase the
first term
uh the first term decreases like one
over n uh with the number of clients and
this term log n Over N minus 1 is
actually also upper bounded by order one
over n
so uh the the last term that's remaining
is the C and the uh this bound is under
particular set of assumptions in
particular assume that the data is
sampled across the clients in ID fashion
um and the other is the fact that we
assume that the sample sequence gradient
has a sigma lock concave distribution
this get this assumption is not
necessary what's most important is IID
so if you discard the second assumption
you're going to get the second term but
this first term all you can
argue is that it's something that the K
is within
so uh this is what we have for a single
around leakage and the beautiful thing
is that you can extend this uh this
guarantee uh using uh chain rule into a
multi-round leakage guarantee where you
get a a linear scaling with the number
of training grounds uh it's been shown
yesterday that I mean in terms of the
French privacy this is not necessarily
something that you do not necessarily
have a linear leakage this is the
current bond that we have but we'll show
through experiments that it's not also
linear in terms of mutual information
okay so uh this is the the main uh
bounds that we have for the leakage now
how does this compare uh experimentally
so in order to do this we
um
compare that on on two uh
pretty small data sets uh the mnist and
the software 10 and the reason for that
is that in order to actually measure
Mutual information we have to run
um we use the mutual information neural
estimated and to do that we have to you
have to run an experiment multiple times
and then these represent samples that
are then fed to that estimated to
computer information
so the First Column represents the uh
the part of the experiments that aligns
with uh with our Theory and uh in
particular here we're using the SGD
protocol and you can see that as the
number of uh the number of users uh
sorry the number of users increase uh
the leakage that you get uh decays with
like order one over n
we see very similar trends when we use
the FED averaging protocol or fat box
which just uh some form of recordization
or fat average
[Music]
the second thing I want to highlight
here is that uh how this this uh metric
um in yeah
um so if you go back a previous slide uh
you know the second term log one it's
really scaling linearly with d and T
right yeah so are you assuming that the
number of users way more than the
millions of parameters
is D like a local model or the global
model it's I mean it's the same size oh
it's the same size okay
um
I mean this bound it could be back
whisper on the next slide oh this is so
so greatly if this is for sing around
leakage okay right so this this is
nothing become T okay right uh I'll be
showing how it is
it's kind of a different model so this
is this one the first one is logistic
regression model the other is single
layer uh single episode
yeah yeah it's not like uh yeah it's not
like a resonant model but I don't know
but then so normalize you're just
dividing by the entropy yes
it's kind of like a fixed I mean
um I can import what it is in bits but
then uh it's not necessarily descriptive
from one data set to the other so the
what we decided to choose just to
compute the interview of data set and
the interview of one clients
again
so uh so this is
um so the okay so here we are recording
two figures at the same time one is the
uh the estimated initial information
leakage and the other is the success uh
of the of the modeling of Canadian
version attack particular using uh we
are using uh Peaks signals ratio to
evaluate this performance but you can
also look at it qualitatively by saying
that the image is actually become the
reconstructed image is becoming worse
and worse as the number of points in the
system are increased
okay now uh the last thing that I want
to discuss in this part is uh how does
the privacy and model how does the
privacy in the accuracy change as you
run uh as you run the experiment so this
is measuring the accumulative
accumulative leakage in particular we
are looking at the leakage after a
particular number of rounds uh
so you can follow the stress basically
saying that we start with this
particular model accuracy after one
round and this is the leakage that we
have and then this is following this
this is how the leakage and the model
accuracy work so you can see that at the
very uh in the in the very early rounds
the the the model accuracy is growing
pretty fast and the leakage is growing
kind of linearly with it and then after
that the model accuracy kind of plateaus
and the leakage is still increasing
monotonically but it's uh at some at
some training at some training grounds
the the leakage uh is not
growing linearly uh so the takeaway that
we want to say here is that
um as you train more and more you're
actually leaking more information not
necessarily in the linear fashion but uh
you have to make a conscious choice
about when to stop because
um you see here in even in both data
sets
uh after this particular stage you're
just gaining very small in terms of
access in terms of percentages but the
leakage has been almost I don't know yes
has almost tripled so uh it's kind of a
design choice about when do you stop the
training right
so this is kind of the first part of the
talk that I want to wear I want to
highlight some some of the results we
have in terms yeah
so is this accumulated leakage so how
does it go down no
well no I think this one I think
yeah so I think yeah that's like if you
go to the left a little yeah
oh that's that weird point there yeah
this one
no actually it's just increasing just
going up
yeah but
[Music]
so I'm going to assume you're not doing
any DP right now
this is just sending a role model with
secure aggregation uh no we're not doing
anything
but so
it's kind of interesting to to see that
okay the guarantees that you can get
using security irrigation so okay I have
to figure it you cannot give guarantees
a security
don't give the Friendship privacy
guaranteed using old security it's very
easy to construct examples
but you can also think of the uh the
other users in the system as if they are
inducing noise to your own protection
and it is kind of an open top
question about whether you can you know
you don't necessarily need to add noise
everywhere in the space of the model you
might want to just add noise in places
where
um let's say the Subspace where you do
not get any protection from the other
users
but as of now we're not really looking
at TP at all
okay so uh the second part will be
talking about how to train uh group Fair
models and uh using infinite learning
and in particular we'll be relying on uh
secure aggregation a lot here in our
computations
so the first part I'll run through it
because today we gave a very uh nice
introduction to it and thicker we are
targeting uh training uh globally Fair
model in terms of group fairness and
there are multiple ways of looking at it
equal distribution or equal performance
and multiple metrics to evaluate both of
them so in equal performance you want to
equate the through positive rates
whereas in something like equal
distribution you'd like to just look at
the model at the output distribution
yeah okay and there are a lot of ways to
uh um to Target this bias that you have
in training through uh that can be
basically category categorized into
three main methods pre-processing in
processing post-processing as slavia
described like a few minutes earlier
uh
but let me now get to the challenges of
of trying to do uh Fair training in
Federated learning in particular the the
main challenge that you will face right
away is the fact that uh the
distribution that you are targeting to
be fair with respect to which is a
global distribution is actually divided
across the different clients and each of
these different clients might not have a
representative distribution of uh of the
global distribution
uh so one example of that is if you look
at data from the uh uh census then you
see that different risk distributions
across uh I took me first time I
presented this I had some chance with
naming the state so this is Main and
then
yeah and the state on the top right and
then the in California I see a different
different race distribution and also
different number of Representative
points in each of the clients
so uh uh what this uh what this would
lead you to believe is that local device
thing cannot necessarily guarantee
Global fairness and uh
um we can actually uh create some toy
examples to test this out so we took uh
one famous data set the other data set
that flavius talking about and partition
it into different uh different silos and
you can see that if you are in the
homogeneous case then
um so the the blue bar is basically
representing the performance of
Federated averaging where you're running
without any care about fairness the
orange part the orange bar is
representing locally waiting uh where
you're applying a debicing method but
you're applying it on the local data set
and in the homogeneous case this is
pretty good uh because it's a
representative yet noisy uh sample of
the full data set first you go to more
heterogeneous settings the performance
the gates and uh just to uh
show a representation this uh this is
what the accuracy drops like but you can
see that the range is not necessarily
very bad okay so local fairness does not
imply Global fairness this is a takeaway
and the question that we want to go
after is how do we go about talking
right so we present an algorithm to do
that uh uh it's interesting it's still
interesting our problem what kind of
theoretical guarantees can we put on it
but this is how our intuition to solve
this goes
so in in Federated learning uh you'd
like to solve uh an objective function
that looks like this and typically uh we
await the local losses that you have
across the clients by the number of data
points that these clients have
and the idea that you have is that we
would like to apply local debiasing in
order to preserve the privacy because
you're not shared we do not want to
share any information about what the
data sets look like with the server but
uh since local devices that is only
addressing the local view of fairness
which is which can be different from the
global view we would like to favor the
clients whose local fairness metrics are
close to the global fairness match
uh so how do you find the global
inference Matrix this is a reminder of
the previous slides I'll be using EOD
the Equal Opportunity difference as an
example progress of the talk but uh on
on binary on binary data set on binary
decision data sets uh the you you define
it as the true positive rate for group
zero and minus a true positive rate for
group one and if you want to apply this
locally you can just you basically just
extend the definition by only looking at
the data set at the client k
okay so uh normally if you get the
following updates uh after one round of
training then if you apply a Federated
averaging then you get a point that
looks like this now uh the main idea
that we are presenting here is that we
would also like to view a
how these models are looking on the
furnace plane in particular you can look
at any fairness metric as a linear
projection from the model outputs so uh
let's say that this is the projection
that you should have gotten from the
global view so this is the global metric
and each of the clients have a local
view F1 F2 and F3 assuming three clients
here then what you would do is you would
increase the weights uh in the
aggregation for clients one and two
because they have very uh similar
projections or very close projections to
the global view and you decrease the
weight of F3 because it's very far away
from your Global projection
so doing something like that will end
will will lead you towards a model that
is
um a little bit uh
geared towards X1 and X2 because they
have higher weights in the aggregation
okay so how do we do that in the
algorithm
well uh the first thing that we do is uh
the the server and the clients
collaboratively compute how far each of
the clients are from the global view so
uh using this difference Delta K and
then for clients that are higher than
the average uh we increase the rates for
clients that are lower than the average
we decrease the rates and we normalize
and repeat this in every cycle of the
training
now one important thing to uh to
highlight here is that here we're
assuming that we are able to compute
what the global metric looks like
so uh how do we do that so the global
metric can we can actually rewrite it in
terms of we can take the through
positive rate difference and rewrite it
in the following form
just checking that it's there okay and
uh basically you can see here that this
part of the expression is actually a
local a local information that each of
the clients can compute whereas uh the
screen parts are global data set
statistics so for example if you're
looking at a healthcare application this
is basically saying the percentage of
individuals in the data set that have
disease X from group a this is the
number of points at this particular
client divided by the total number of
points
so uh
Okay so
so each so since this is local
information and this is a global data
statistic that you can that is known or
you can if you want you can compute it
before training using uh an invocation
of the secure hydration protocol then
each of these terms can actually be
computed locally about client K and then
you just aggregate this using secure
aggregation to get the global Finance
metric in every uh training ground
so but with this we can uh just describe
what the algorithm looks like in every
round in every round each client trains
locally and applies its own local
devices
and then the server computes a global
metric using the equation that we
described the previous Slide by using
the secure aggregation protocol and then
broadcast this to the client and then
each of the clients uh with the server
will do another round aggregation to
compute the aggregation weights and
finally we multiply each fine with
weights model updates by that and
multiply it to the way its model updates
by that and then we the server collected
into the new Global model using secure
aggregation
okay so how does this uh algorithm
perform
uh we first tested on two uh data sets
the other than the compass data set
and uh it shows it shows that it works
pretty well uh in particular uh
in particular we see that's resilient uh
in terms of uh when we look at different
heterogeneity levels just explain here
how we are creating this heterogeneous
distributions where uh uh using the
tristat distribution to divide the
points into different silos and the the
as the alpha becomes smaller the data
sets become more heterogeneous and the
particular parameter that we divide by
is actually the the sensor attribute
that we're looking at
okay so this is how it looks like in
terms of fairness but we can also see
when we compare it uh when we compare
its its privacy penalty that we are
getting very good reductions in in the
in the in the furnace metric with very
with very limited penalties on the on
the accuracy performance
so this is uh the performance on menu
partition data set but uh uh we also
looked at data sets that are more
naturally partitioned particularly
looked at this ACS ACS income data set
which has like 1 million uh 600 000 data
points where naturally here you take
each state as as your clients we end up
with professional clients and uh we
showed that you can still get a very
good equal opportunity reduction uh when
uh training using our Fair Federate
average in government
so I think I'm just about the time so
the conclusion that that I wanna uh
leave you with is that secure
aggregation allows you to hide
information it doesn't allow you too
hard to hide clients so if you're
looking to infer whether the client is
in a system or not this is not the
protocol do it you're assuming that
other users are helping you in the
protection uh using the their updates
that they inject which can in our
lessons you can treat them basically as
a noise at your own update and then you
can use secure aggression by invoking it
in different stages to train uh Fair
Machinery models the good thing about
our protocol is that it's it does not
necessarily enforce a particular devices
method that the clients need to use so
each client can actually have some
clients can have no debussing at all
some clients can have uh we waiting
sometimes have another different device
method we should experiments here only
early waiting but the if you go to the
people CR other interesting
um ablation studies
and this is what I want to say about
security irrigation I don't want to
leave I mean back to Lita's question
security irrigation is not the old old
protection and I just want to leave like
one slide to highlight that is that
um it is assuming a very big uh level of
trust so it's assuming that the server
is only curious it doesn't necessarily
do any particular issues it doesn't try
to modify the training in any way
and one of the very great things about
DP is that it's very resilient to
auxiliary information
but that is not the only thing that the
client can export so for example
um you can actually induce some model
discrepancy in the training and that can
leak information in a catastrophic way
so again I don't want to destroy
everything that I've built throughout
the paper throughout the talk but I just
want to highlight the limitations that
want to be fair
um so the idea here is that uh it's
gonna be like two two more slides but
the idea is that if the server uh is not
sending the same Global model to all
clients
let's say that each coin starts with X1
X2 and xn here I'm putting in with
different colors because they're
different then you can actually leak
information in a very uh bad way and
there is a very nice toy model that we
came up with that does that
so ideas of following is that
you can actually take
you can actually take the original model
and just add to it
um like a prefix of of your own design
and that prefix will be different across
different points so you put a two linear
layers and then you add a set of
convolutional layers but these
convolutional layers are the only thing
that is differing so client number one
gets the screen part and everything here
zero plus these layers plan number two
gets the blue part non-zero and
everything else is zero plus these
layers and when you do that when you
when the clients do back propagation and
they compute the gradients the gradients
you can design the weights in the fully
connected layer and the pollution layer
such that the images appear very clearly
inside the gradient updates
and when you aggregate them since uh
since this part for client one will only
have non-zero Updates this part for
client will only have non-zero updates
and so on and so forth then when you
aggregate them together each client's
data will appear very distinctly from
each other and we show that you can
actually reconstruct it in a very crazy
manner like
this is not really trying to apply any
generative model to recreate the images
you just take the take the gradients
that you get divide them by a constant
and you're able to create recreate like
81 percent of the the data points
towards uh the model trained on so this
is a very recent paper that we put on
archive
um yeah it's uh saying securegation is
private but it's only private if you
really have um
very great trust in what the server is
doing
and then I'd like to conclude my talk
and hopefully
[Applause]
Global fairness problem do you also
encounter scenarios where the local
fairness is like Global friends achieved
but local fairness is not going down
especially in nether's case there will
be some clients where that happens like
most of the clients uh will have a low
local fairness
uh but there will be one or two clients
with those defensive very uh is very far
away from the program especially
the other question I have is here
sometimes is clients don't respond in
Federation
so yeah yeah that's that we we haven't
really so what's yours what we're
considering now is uh so so to be back
they were considering the side of
setting so uh the each fine is able to
compute even what you call a local
fairness metric as a client is just one
individual with one particular sense of
attribute then the definition of local
Finance is that when it really breaks
right so in a silent setting you're
passing that everyone is going to be
responding it's not like a random access
kind of acceptable
so I have this thought about Computing F
Global in a Federated way itself
yeah I think
so I mean so so the the central thing
that we're trying to do here is that
make sure that everything that whatever
whatever you're Computing it is computed
inside or encapsulated by the securation
protocol so here in order to be good at
Global you are relying on some local
updates that the clients are doing and
then you're aggregating these uh sorry
you're relying on local computations the
clients are doing and then you're
aggregating that together so I think it
should piggyback on the the previous
questions so if
some clients are only updating and then
a client only has a limited ad size I
think you may be able to still create
unbiased estimators for the the local
information and then over time it should
average itself
I see
but what do you mean by overtime
so the clients are going to participate
in multiple rounds and every time there
is a batch of their data that you're
going to see and then so you may be able
to still get convergence qualities
similar to Federated averaging
but aren't you in that case that the
model is not changing across these
different
well like because the global the global
Finance is defined in terms of the
current particular model right
yeah let's take that that's fine
okay thank you so much
uh the post recession now upstairs uh
because we have a break
it should be cookies and coffee up there
another thing I wanted to say is so
again poster session goes into 5 30 but
the building is locked at five so if you
leave you can't get back in also the
door to the second floor